I think we are inferred real treat today
um so um I I a lot of you have um have
expressed to me and others about how
they really wish there was somebody who
um
understand this whole quantum gravity
thing that uh that
you get more and more interesting from
the point of view of uh you know if
you're doing Quantum complexity or
Quantum cryptography and we all talk
about it but do we really know what we
are talking about so
so I reached out to Patrick and you know
I'm really delighted was really
delighted that he agreed to do this to
give a couple of lectures uh trying to
introduce us to uh to what really uh you
know a physicists we will call them
gravity but but expressed in computer
science terms so that's the it's a heavy
lift but but there's uh probably nobody
better than Patrick to do this with his
you know as most of you know all of you
know uh he he did much of the work at
this intersection of quantum information
and gravity you know started it off with
um let's work with Jordan presco and
then and Hayden so
all right
well thanks
as much was saying and you've probably
heard ideas from Quantum information
have played a really important role
probably the most important role in
pushing our understanding of the
structure and of space and time over the
past 10 years or so
really resolving questions that had been
around for almost half a century uh and
no one had really understood how to deal
with
and
that's exciting right idea the ideas are
well entropies Quantum error correction
even complexity of it have all played an
important role and I'm going to try to
tell you a little bit about that before
we get started and uh the way that I got
into this was through something called
the black hole information Paradox I'm
not going to tell you
really much about that during this talk
um
but I will at least to try to motivate
why we have to why there's an issue why
do we have to reconcile uh gender
relativity and quantum mechanics what do
they have to uh what's the conflict
there well general relativity give you
know tell us about the geometry of space
and time and the most basic coarse grain
property of the geometry is the causal
structure what can affect what uh and so
here this is uh my anthropomorphan
anthropomorphization of a black hole uh
you know there's someone who wants to
get some something out and and can't get
it as being held back in a black hole
there's a region there's a of space time
uh that cause general relativity
predicts cannot affect anything else
um now quantum mechanics which we hear
all know and love
um
it's most basic property if you think
what is the formal structure of quantum
mechanics well it's an inner product
space the state space is in their
product space and time Evolution uh is
the natural morphisms of that or
isomorphism of that inner product space
it's unitary uh time Evolution and so
it's reversible and so the most basic
property of quantum mechanics is its
reversibility at some level uh and so
there we have our two you know our two
great theories of nature uh there are
two basic properties and it just so
happens that when you try to combine
them you learn that black holes
evaporate slowly
um and eventually evaporate away and
because of the causal structure
predicted by general relativity it looks
like nothing that was inside can affect
anything uh in the future and that leads
to Pure States a pure state that
collapses into a black hole evolving
into a mixed state violating the uh yeah
most beautiful Central property of
quantum mechanics and so quantum
mechanics wants to be unitary general
relativity combined with quantum
mechanics does not that creates you know
a conflict that needs to be reconciled
and I'll just fast forward it seems that
the resolution of this conflict is that
uh quantum mechanics wins but it wins in
a very subtle and interesting way which
we may get to at the end
so that's what got me into this uh into
this business and usually when I give
talks uh you know to an audience of
computer scientists uh my my working
principle is that I have as few
equations as possible and I draw lots of
pictures that people can get a an
intuitive understanding of what's going
on and I imagine most of the people or
many of the people in this room have
seen talks about quantum gravity that
are of that character whether by me or
Lenny suskin he writes even fewer words
than me his slides often have no words
at all no symbols and just pictures and
it's I think it's easy yeah in this
audience if you only see such things you
say oh that's a beautiful story but all
people do in that business is they come
up with weird thought of thought
experiments and they can weird
hypotheses and yeah they reason with
pictures and you know is there any
substance to any of that uh you know can
you calculate and so what I want to do
yeah so this couple of lectures is going
to be very different than what I would
normally do I'd normally try to tell you
a story with lots yeah with lots of
pictures and not many symbols I'm
actually going to try to show you
symbols and we're going to try to do
some calculations uh that illustrate
um
well they are not really that bad at the
end of the day uh but are extremely
powerful
um
yeah
oh well I just want to talk
yeah I mean you can make it non-mutitary
right I mean you can talk about you and
evolution if you want
um but then you
so
but the the usual formulation of quantum
mechanics as a as a theory yeah as a
sort of fundamental theory is just yeah
cats evolving in helper space right uh
the mixtape Evolution yeah the the
channel picture is usually viewed as
something uh
derived from that but so there's a whole
story to be had about whether you you
can make a self-consistent you know
well-behaved Theory uh which does
actually generate the mixtape Evolution
without you know uncontrolled Heating
and so on but I just want to I just
wanted to
to illustrate that some
that's where the the where the conflict
you know seems to be and if you want to
preserve quantum mechanics in the way we
in the basic way we usually think about
it you run into problems yeah maybe
there's a a version of quantum mechanics
that is naturally talking about mixed
States and mixtape Evolution that would
be that would be fine but ah
all right so the themes of these
lectures uh I just want to
I want to kind of illustrate to you how
geometry uh encodes quantum mechanics
and gravitational theories and theories
that actually uh have emergent gravity
um and the geometry that we're going to
be seeing again and again and again is
the geometry of extremal surfaces uh you
know surfaces of minimal area minimal
length uh minimizing some other quantity
so extremal surfaces are kind of
everywhere in this story
um the quantum information ideas that
are Central uh are entropy Quantum error
correction and it seems you know
complexity
oh strangely enough
um and in these theories of gravity
we'll see there are there are radical
departures from locality as we would
normally understand it yeah uh you know
like relativistic causal structure
um but they're shielded from observation
and that's where complexity comes in
all right so what hat am I wearing
you know if I'm with my quantum gravity
friends and I'm usually wearing the
computer scientists hat or the
information theorists had at least you
know and I I try to think in terms of
quantum information uh but here yeah
with my computer scientist friends are
going to try to wear the physicist hat
uh and so uh that's the language the
language that I'd be speaking a little
bit and so our plan for the couple of
lectures
um we're going to start off by just
thinking about the geometry of
anti-decider space that's not our
universe as you'll see very clearly in a
few moments but it's one in which it's
easier to think about quantum gravity
um and then we're going to talk about
the formula for entropy in in such
theories uh just Von Neumann entropy
it's geometrical
um we're going to talk about the
holographic principle or the map yeah
how you map uh from the gravity Theory
to this you know regular quantum
mechanical Theory and that's actually a
story of quantum error correction
and finally we're going to well not
quite fine we're going to move on to a
geometrical property of these geometries
Wormhole volume and see that it seems to
be connected in some surprising way uh
to computational complexity and then if
there's time at the end we're going to
get to one of the greatest hits uh which
is actually calculating what happens in
black hole evaporation that's the
question that's been around for 50 years
and we'll see that the conclusions are
really uh have radical consequences for
our understanding of the structure of
space-time
so ads CFT it's been around for a long
time since 1997 and it's a
correspondence uh as you've again many
of you probably heard uh between a
quantum gravity Theory and the quantum
gravity theory is supposed to live
inside the soup can actually a cylinder
yeah an infinite cylinder
um
and
we'll say it's a d plus one dimensional
gravity Theory so D plus one space time
Dimension so D spatial dimensions and
one time Dimension uh and the
correspondence uh asserts that this
quantum gravity Theory which might be
String Theory who knows what you know
just some something uh it's actually
equivalent
to
a regular quantum mechanical Theory with
no gravity uh defined on the boundary
so the boundary is the outside of the
cylinder uh it has one fewer spatial
Dimension so it has D space-time
Dimensions it has no gravity and so many
of you most are probably not field
theorists it's a it's a Quantum field
Theory but just think of it as a ring of
cutus and the cutits can interact with
each other yeah uh nearest neighbor and
that's a pretty good picture of of what
this theory is it has some particular uh
set of interactions
um
okay yeah I mean the boundary or just oh
yeah time is the vertical Direction
okay yeah yeah and so the Ring of cudis
is like a a cross section
okay so we want to understand the
geometry of anti-decider space
um
and why it's helpful for area so why is
it why do physicists like think about
anti the sitter space well it's finite
so if you ever took a any kind of
physics class where you solve some
partial differential equations you
probably found it's easier to do that if
you put everything in a box right and so
this puts the universe in a box uh and
makes it easier to deal with
um well let's actually work out the
geometry
so
um
the simplest way to talk about the
geometry
um
in what we call the bulk the interior
I'm going to take a spatial slice right
so the spatial slice is just a disc and
I'm going to cut the disc at some point
and unwrap it okay so when I unwrap it
my boundary becomes a line and the bulk
is the upper half space
okay
and
what do we need to be able to talk about
geometry
we need a metric
okay so it's asymptotically anti-decider
in these theories because we're allowed
to put stars and black holes and whatnot
you know deep inside here uh and so deep
inside the geometry is going to be
distorted according to general
relativity uh but then out near the
boundary yeah it's all asymptotically
going to be this anti-decenter space and
if we don't put any stars in or any
black holes then it is an anti-disitter
space
and so the metric uh
is how we calculate
um distances in the geometry
uh and so imagine yeah so this is
supposed to be distance we have an x
coordinate and a y coordinate uh forget
about time for the moment and as written
right now we're just expressing the
Pythagorean theorem right that the
square of the distance is the sum of the
change in the horizontal and the
vertical directions uh and you know if
you have a curve you should add up the
infinite intestinal contributions from
each part of the curve in order to
figure out the length of the Curve
top uh Top Line is about okay it's only
white is it oh sorry this is a spatial
slice and the bulk goes up to Infinity
uh
so I
um I'm going to say it the the
coordinates here are defined for y
greater than zero and Y equals zero is
the boundary
so as you go higher and higher on the
right hand side you're going closer and
closer to the center exactly
yeah so this is only covering a portion
but it would actually be a big portion
yes Professor how should I understand
the boundary physically like if you tell
me that the D plus one space is you know
one dimension for time D dimensional for
the space in the universe say how should
I understand physically this boundary ah
good so
I think the best way to think about it
is to say really imagine that we have
this theory of inter of interacting
cubits okay
um in some regime
they can be described using some
effective Theory right like the world
here in this room is described by the
standard model and quantum mechanics but
for many purposes I can actually just
use classical classical mechanics of you
know people in chairs and what not to
describe what's going on and so the
boundary Theory
yeah in a certain regime and we'll talk
exactly really about the details of
regime but weak gravity is one one
property and large D of the cutest
um
has an effective Theory and the
effective theory is very interesting the
effective theory has one extra spatial
dimension
and
it has gravity in it so I think that's
the that's the way to think about at
least that's one way to think about the
bulk uh is it's an effective theory for
the for the boundary
oh and I I asserted a stronger statement
that there was an isomorphism but you
you can you know you can just say if you
want to be uh
practical about it right the bulk you
know the bulk is just an effective
description of the boundary the
effective description somehow has
equations of motion that look like
gravity
yeah
just very naive question why is y not
bounded above
well why is y not bounded above
um
so we've cut out an open portion of the
bulk or rather we're left with a rather
an open set in the bulk and so we just
uh
we just map the the the open set up all
the way to white white or we like why be
unbounded
okay
so we're talking about the Pythagorean
theorem yeah sure go ahead
so what does it mean to have a
three-dimensional theory that
description
oh uh we have not abandoned locality at
this point
yeah so that was a bit of a preview I
think for the moment uh the bulk here is
described by general relativity
um sorry can you pull up just a little
bit so why is the y equal to zero is
laundry but uh where this y was going up
why
um I mean it's just a choice an
arbitrary Choice yeah but it's just some
patch of coordinates that I've chosen in
here
um are you going to finish the metric I
mean yes oh okay okay coming back to the
metric right so I just I I understand
but another important point about this
metric is that there's there's time in
there right and so uh when we measure
you know this notion of distance that we
have it also yeah if time isn't changing
it's just our usual notion of distance
um but if time is changing and let's say
say that space is thick you know our
spatial coordinates are picked our time
coordinate changes then we get a
negative number for our distance and
that should actually be interpreted as
the time in experienced by an observer
that follows that trajectory
the so-called proper time uh and yeah so
this is that's how you measure this
notion of distance
um and as a as Eddie said I hadn't
finished the metric uh there's a crucial
feature what what makes this yeah which
curves this geometry it wasn't curved to
begin with it was minkowski space you
know just empty uh flat space uh I
weight The Distance by the y coordinate
squared or by the the distance squared
by the y coordinate squared oh and so
let's try to get a feel for what that
means what that does
and there's door reach here today
I don't see her ah
she's
listening but she's not oh she's
listening but she's not here okay uh so
you're gonna have to blame to reach
is that what I've chatting with her
yesterday she said you have to give them
exercises because if you don't give them
exercise they won't learn anything and
so uh we're gonna pause I'm gonna let
you do some calculations so we're going
to talk about a spatial slice yeah one
sec or actually no go ahead
where's time in your first picture
pictures the like uh like uh where is
time in uh so
in in this picture I took a spatial
slice with no time fixed and I'm yeah
I'm just looking at that
okay
so let's use this metric to actually
calculate some distances in this
geometry to get a feel for what the
geometry how the geometry behaves so
let's take a what a line segment a
horizontal line segment so the y
coordinate is fixed and it goes from X1
to X2 and let's calculate you know the
distance uh from the first point to the
second point
and how are we going to calculate that
distance
well
we're going to parameterize the curve by
its x coordinate so we have to take
infinitesimal steps uh
and if we use the metric formula
um
I've substituted the metric there then
you have done my physicist style
calculus right uh
I've pulled that a DX squared and so I
can divide by DX squared as I integrate
this is my formula for the distance
right I have to take the square root of
the metric because the metric is giving
me the squares of the distance the
distance is and I have to calculate this
thing
so how does
what is the rate of change of Y
as I with respect to X
can anyone say like in this line segment
how does how does y change as I move
along the Y SEC the line segment
zero okay good so we have a pretty easy
integral to do and so Y is a constant
right so we can pull y out of that
integral
so what is the distance uh
from point one to point two they want to
raise their hand
so it's like like X2 minus X1 over y
exactly all right excellent job Scott
I'd say I remember calculus except it
doesn't require it
does not require calculus uh all right
so what do we observe from this uh well
we observed that the length of this line
segment goes to Infinity as we approach
the boundary
right
um and I wrote here the boundary is
infinitely long that's actually a weaker
statement than what we care about uh any
any physical yeah if I if I choose a
portion of the boundary that looks like
it's finite length uh in uh
in terms of these coordinates it's
actually infinitely long right so
there's an infinite amount of space uh
out of the boundary
um now let's do a more interesting
example
let's now take a line segment that is
constant in the x coordinate
um but goes from you know some quantity
Epsilon so I want to think Epsilon is
kind of close to the boundary up to some
y
um
this is another exercise let's see how I
hmm okay
and I gave it away there
well you should go this way
all right
so
what is missing here
well limits of integration so what
should I be integrating from too
all right so from Epsilon to y
EP uh and I have the weight of the
metric the 1 over y squared but I'm
integrating with respect to Y is which
is
the square root of y d y squared our d y
is the square root of Dy squared
and so after I take my square roots
which I'm sure everyone can done can do
what what happens if I integrate
Vlog yeah exactly
so I get the log of Y over Epsilon
um
and so what does that mean if I fix my
y-coordinate
I can bring Epsilon closer and closer to
the boundary uh when Epsilon goes to
zero that that distance diverges
right and so the boundary is infinitely
far away from every point in the
interior
right every point in the bulk
um so that's a so this is kind of a very
interesting box right so the Box yeah is
infinitely large
and it's infinitely far away and so you
might think well it's not much of a box
right uh yes you might get a question
uh
that it is a shortest path but yeah
that's an additional yeah
um oh actually
yeah we'll we'll see we'll see it in a
little bit we're going to do that too
yeah but if if this is a space time and
it'll base Einstein's equations what
type of matter distribution or energy
distribution gives rise to this
this one empty space
this is flat
um
specific boundary conditions okay so
it's a flat space
empty space with a negative cosmological
concept what was it cost much constant
then that would be in there and the
certainly Einstein's equations would
show that there's a custom watch yeah
okay yeah so there is a cosmological
there's a cosmological concept
gotta do that
okay
um so to visualize this you know it's a
logarithm
and so
uh
well I've taken lines I just divided by
two yeah the distance to the boundary by
two at each point uh and so these lines
are equally yeah in this rendition these
lines are equally spaced from the
boundary uh but you can fit an infinite
number of equally spaced lines uh
between here and the boundary and there
was a hand up yeah
depends only on why what's basically
what does that means why does it only
depend on water depends on why your
Matrix space Matrix
oh so why only online yeah
so
I mean just somebody says it's a choice
uh like there's a there's a direction
yeah in in the
in this picture
where we have the circle it's the radial
direction that controls the scale
um okay
so one one last uh little exercise for
thinking about this geometry let's
imagine shining a laser out of the
boundary
right and so
um in the bulk we're standing at some
point why not and we just aim directly
at the boundary straight at the boundary
so there's no going to be no change in X
and
you know the the light Ray is going to
head out to the boundary and let's
actually impose reflecting boundary
conditions on the uh reflect yeah let's
ask that the the boundary be reflecting
um it's a boundary so we have to see
what happens when you get there
um and think about what will happen okay
so
what is the main property of the
propagation of light
yeah in uh in space what what we all
know about light
sorry speed is constant the speed is
constant right
um and
so here I'm actually just going to set
the speed of light as equal to one
throughout the talk
and so what is a what kind of trajectory
will a light Ray take
um with respect to this metric
what will DS squared be
for a light Ray
yeah it'll be zero right because it
covers the same amount of space as it
covers in time as long as we measure
space and time in the same units that's
the property of light and so light like
trajectory is one that has DS squared
equals zero
um
and so
let's think about what happens here's
our metric
uh
GS squared is equal to zero we're
pointing straight yeah we're pointing
straight out at the boundary so there's
no change in x
um
and what does that tell us about delta T
right it tells us that delta T the
amount of time that it takes to get up
to the boundary is
why not
that's interesting
right
um
so if we ask about shining a laser out
at the boundary here's a space-time
diagram so this is my y coordinate my
time coordinate I Shine from y naught
towards the boundary in the space-time
diagram uh the Y naught uh the y
coordinate the rate of change in the y
coordinate and the time chord are the
same so there's 45 degrees 45 degrees
coming out
and so the total time that this light
Ray takes to get out to the boundary and
come back is twice why not
now what happened to the 1 over y
squared here
um good so
this is the coordinate time
right not the proper time
but the coordinate time is finite
um you can calculate the the proper time
as well but the key message is that this
boundary even though it's infinitely far
away
well you can interact with it right that
if you shine a laser at the boundary
yeah the light beam it's going to hit
the boundary come back at you in a
finite amount of time
um and so
that's the sense in which you've put the
universe in a box
right so even though the boundary is
infinitely large even though it's
infinitely far away it does actually uh
keep everything together right so for
example uh yeah an example which might
come back you know come back up later if
we had a black hole and black holes you
know they evaporate slowly as I was
saying uh in flat space the radiation
just goes off to Infinity right the
irradiation once once it's yeah once it
comes out of the black hole it can just
propagate out and out and out and out
farther and further and further and
further away uh and so the black hole
will actually will evaporate and
disappear
but in ads or an anti-decider space if
you have a black hole it will radiate
the radiation will hit the boundary you
reflect it and come back
and so the black hole and its radiation
will come to equilibrium
that's because the the black hole
reabsorbed the radiation that came back
at it and so black holes in ABS is
unless they're really tiny they don't
evaporate they just sit there
no
and I should write this up
doesn't the proper time have to be zero
because it's a light Ray
um so the proper time experienced By the
Light Ray yeah but not you know if
you're sitting there you shine your your
flashlight you care about your proper
time and that will also be finite but
something different yeah
okay
so one last calculation to get a feel
for this geometry uh geodesics
um so here I have two points on the
boundary and I have a curve connecting
them
foreign
of theta so the curve is parameterized
by some parameter Theta and I want to
know what's the shortest yeah the
shortest path
from uh from the left point on the
boundary to the right point on the
boundary
um
so how do I figure out the shortest path
I have to write down the distance yeah
or the length of the curve
um and so I can use my metric
all right
DS by D Theta right oh D Theta
and
then I have to figure out how to write
down what is the metric I'm going to
extremise this so the metric
um this is a spatial slice so there's no
time
so there was a DX squared a d y squared
and my DOT means differentiate with
respect to Theta so because I
parameterized with respect to Theta and
then I have the 1 over y waiting because
there's one over y squared in the metric
and I have to take the square root
so I have to take this function
uh which gives me the length of the
curve and extremise that over all curves
if I want to know uh the minimum the
length of the minimal curve and find the
middle minimal curve
and if you're a physicist or if you've
taken you know analytical mechanics uh
this is the kind of calculation uh that
you've done a hundred or a thousand
times uh and it just makes you feel warm
and fuzzy inside right it's a little bit
like yeah if you've uh
like like you doing turning's
diagonalization argument to show that
they're uncomputable functions right
just one of these things that you do it
just it makes you just feel so happy
um and so uh since there are people in
the Stream I imagine who haven't uh gone
through that oh
had that experience I'll just show you
how you do the calculation
so if we have some
candidate curve gamma knot and we want
to know is gamma not extremal right a
minimal length curve or a saddle or uh
maximal length curve we that we perturb
it
so gamma of theta is my perturbed curve
there's the perturbed the original curve
uh and so I perturb it by Epsilon some
small number
oops
time some curve that I put which is also
parameter parameterized by Theta which
is just the difference between the
original and the new one
um and I have to be a little bit careful
with these perturbations I want the new
curve to start at end at the same points
as the original one and so the
perturbations should be zero uh at the
original at the left point and the right
point which I'm calling theta equals
zero and pi
and I want an extremal path and so again
we're we're doing calculus
um which means that I want the
derivative of the curve length with
respect to Epsilon to be zero right uh
regardless of how I choose the
perturbations
um all right well it's calculus
um what do I do I had this function
which was the infinitesimal contribution
to the length of the curve it was a
function of three arguments right y the
derivative of x and the derivative of y
with respect to Theta and so
um what I should do I have to you know
just do my calculus I per I ask how does
f change if the first argument changes a
little bit the second argument changes a
little bit if their argument changes a
little bit and then ask how much does
each argument change
um
so the first argument was y so I
differentiate f with respect to Y and
then I say how does y change
uh
as a function of the perturbation and
then here's the rest of the uh
I think we call that rule in calculus
the other terms that you need now one
thing that's confusing if you ever a
heads up if you're not a physicist and
you uh go and look at these books you
see what's the derivative of f with
respect to Y Dot right you see the
derivative of f with respect to Y you
see well why and why not those are those
are fun those are things that are
related to each other and yeah
um this yeah treat it as treat it just
syntactically y dot is just a symbol
right it's just the second it just
refers to the second argument of the
function right
um so that's the kind of thing that uh
gets people confused
okay
um well
the derivative of y
with respect to or let's see with
respect to Epsilon that picks up the
perturbation
so that's ETA two
and
you have to make a little argument
um but if you ask how does y dot uh vary
as a function of the perturbation
actually that's pretty immediate uh oops
and so there's
how things change
um and what you want to do from this is
you want to extract
um
some kind of condition on the Curve
right from you know from what you see
here uh
and you and the way that you're going to
extract a condition on the curve is by
saying well I want this
expression to be extremal for all
possible eta 1 and 8 is 2. all right but
I don't really know how 802 dot an ETA
one dot behave I don't know what their
boundary conditions are and it's kind of
confusing and see you look at this you
say well how do I get rid of the dots on
801 and eta2
uh
anyone anyone have any ideas you can
think back to those days when you you
know before you were a computer
scientist when at some point you took
calculus you know how do you get rid of
a derivative and an integral
yes you integrate by parts
so you integrate by Parts the boundary
terms are zero because a to one and a
are two are zero at the boundary uh and
when you create by Parts the term picks
up a minus sign
and
the other yeah the other the other thing
you're multiplying gets differentiated
so now we have
uh some expression multiplied by ETA two
another expression multiplied by ETA one
and
all of this should integrate to zero
regardless of what a to 1 and 802 are
the only way that can be true is if the
thing's multiplying a to one and eight
or two are zero
um and so we get to we get some
equations and these are the famous uh or
the special cases of the the famous oil
of LaGrange equations
um and if you're going to optimize
um whether the equations of the calculus
of variations right if you're gonna do
do calculus with functions instead of
just vectors
um so those are the equations that uh
the curve has to satisfy and I'm not
going to subject you to it but if you
you know if you if you want to exercise
your muscles
um
here is a parameterized curve and it
will fix R and we'll vary Theta so it's
a it's a circle actually a semicircle
because we're going from zero to Pi uh
substituting the Euler LaGrange
equations and you'll find that they
satisfied your own generation and so the
geodesics are semicircles
um
and what is the length of that geodesic
by the way
it goes from one point of the boundary
to the other to another point on the
boundary
how far away is the boundary from any
points in the interior
into it so this curve is actually
infinitely long
so we optimized the length of an
infinitely long curve which yeah
I I I I I I didn't have to mention that
to you uh but uh but the the argument
still works right that the the change at
the length of the infinitely long curve
uh was minimized uh by choosing a
semicircle
um
yeah if you want to make this uh if you
want to make everything finite then what
you do is you just cut this off right
you say well I'm going to take two
points that are actually a little bit
inside and then what you get is a
portion of the semicircle so an arc of
the circle but isn't it still
undetermined what's the radius of the
seven Circle uh it's a it is a geodesic
for every radius right so you just
choose the you choose the radius which
is you know if you had two two points uh
it's the semicircle which symmetrically
connects the two points on the boundary
is
yeah you you mean symmetric to the uh to
the corresponding semicircle on the
boundary yeah you know it really is you
know if I had Point P1 yeah and point P2
yeah then uh I have the semicircle which
vertically comes out of P1 and
vertically re-enters a P2 okay
okay okay
so now you are experts on the geometry
of anti-decenter space
um
now
that tells us what the geodesic is once
you have the geodesic you can actually
calculate the curve length if you want
to more calculus uh and you get this
expression
um it's the arc sine of some expression
and I remember that for large values of
the argument arc side is just the
logarithm so this is basically the
logarithm of the distance between uh the
horizontal distance separating the
points
um and so that's how distances behave in
anti-decider space
so many of you have probably seen this
picture before yeah this is the when I'm
talking about anti-decider space this is
basically all that I would show people
usually
um but now hopefully this picture makes
sense right so why do we have yeah these
extra drawings and the spatial slices
because they're representing hyperbolic
space and that's what a spatial slice of
anti-decider is and you see you know
these these kites uh they shrink by a
constant amount uh at every level
um just like the well exactly like anti
like the spatial slices
um and so this is a pretty good picture
of antibter space what it doesn't show
you is the curvature in time which
allows you to send messages to the
boundary well it actually even does that
sort of
[Music]
um well if you think that's light rays
travel at 45 degrees
solve line stress equations with the
negative cosmological constant to get a
you get anti-sitter Space yeah and then
and then the boundary would just be
there yeah but you started with the
boundary that's what I started with the
boundary
um well in a sense that I wanted the
battery the boundary to exist in order
to have yeah but you didn't it was there
from the beginning yeah it was there
yeah it was there from the beginning I
mean the question is that I want to
answer is why do these people doing
quantum gravity why are they always
talking about antibter space rather than
our universe
and the reason
is that they like the boundary
conditions the boundary conditions make
things simpler
okay
but they didn't have to impose them they
found them yeah they said oh well
anti-decenter space hasn't gone
you made this point about black holes
and how they don't evaporate an
anti-disitter space but then you said
unless they're very small which well if
they're so small
that they can evaporate before uh the
radiation
before it has time to bounce back I see
so the ryutakinagi formula what's that
about
um
so suppose that we again have some we're
gonna have some region of the boundary
I'll call it capital a
so here I'm dealing with a
throughout most of the talk I'm just
going to restrict to the case where the
the boundary is a ring plus time uh all
this stuff generalizes but it means that
we don't have to stretch our brains too
much uh to visualize things
um
I want to know remember the boundary is
just a ring of cutits I want to know the
entropy of the reduced density operator
on capital a all right
um so I'll write that as S Sub capital a
um it's there's some constant one over
four times or a Newton's constant I'm
setting speed of light in h bar to one
and it's just the length
um of a curve
um so what curve is it well you can kind
of see I took a gamma that started at
the left end point ended at the right
end point and I allowed it to wiggle
around I think about all such curves and
I find the one with minimal length
and that is going to give me the entropy
when you're talking about the entry what
state are you
sorry which
wow so whatever yeah so this this is a
general formula that works in adscft and
so
um we were thinking about
empty the sitter space corresponds to
the vacuum of the boundary Theory but
this works more generally
um I'm going to come back to the you
know the most general form of the
reutakinaki formula at the end of the
talk
um but I don't want to get into the
details right now I just think it works
pretty generally
yeah and
and but there are 50 many foreign
yes yeah yeah so okay I it's a good
point
um so
let's look at this formula the the
formula says it's the length of the
curve we just found that if the curve
goes all the way up to the boundary the
length is infinite the entropy is
infinite that's telling us that we're
out we have an infinite number of
degrees of freedom in here right that's
not that interesting uh what you really
care about uh
but what you could do is you could say
well it's a ring of cutits uh it's not
an infinite number of cubits you know at
some in the field Theory it would be an
infinite number of cubits but uh
but I only give it a finite resolution
right so I really say that the Q there's
some finite density of qubits Q that's
in there and once you do that the
entropy is finite and when it
corresponds to in this picture is not
going all the way out to the boundary
but going you know but having a cut off
of that of Epsilon right so uh so that
the the length of the curve becomes
finite so there's a correspondence
between how you cut off the geometry and
you make it a bit smaller uh and how you
cut off the field Theory uh meaning that
you you remove the uh the very small
degrees of freedom so what's the D in Q
did
uh roughly speaking I mean it's part of
itself I didn't want to go into the
boundary theory is something like
um a gang Nils Theory a young Mills
Theory uh with an sui gauge Symmetry and
it's the n and then finite or instrument
um
uh
so
and is and is allowed to be finite right
that the infinite end corresponds to
gravity being infinitely weak and so you
actually have a fine idea
Patrick I mean it seems to actually make
more sense when you impose this Epsilon
cut off oh yeah yeah characters like if
it's actually uh it's necessary right
right if you go all the way to the
boundary there's an apparent Paradox
right that if I'm in the bulk and I can
send a light Ray to the boundary and
then see it come back like finite proper
time is experienced by me I can see the
light gray like you know having gone
through an infinite amount of space yeah
well okay so for that part I
um but it becomes less surprising I
would say yeah no but but is is it
there's no Paradox with the fact that it
can yeah I mean I mean I mean suppose
that it's Computing a parody suppose it
keeps flipping its polarization and then
I see the result of it after it does
that infinite
um I mean is is the resolution of this
that you said that the space is
asymptotically ADS which means that like
even though the space is infinite there
can only be a finite amount of stuff in
it uh I think
I have to think through that one I think
the resolution is that you'll have
trouble calculating the parity with
massless degrees of freedom that are
traveling at the speed of light and the
massive degrees of freedom won't be able
to get up to the boundary to find that
time right okay I think I think that's a
consistent with what I would suggesting
yeah
the length of the past like
like is it a phenomenal phenomenon
entropy or which it's about Northern
entropy now how does it Greater the
landslope uh exactly by this formula so
the Von Neumann entropy of the density
operator on this interval
uh the way that you calculate it you
know there's a in this effective Theory
right because remember if you that we
could take the perspective that you know
there's a theory of cubits you know
there's a way to describe it involving
gravity uh the formula becomes this is
what you have between the boundary and
the bulk gives you yeah
uh
so that's it um
and
the simple example of the interval right
we we worked out that the uh the length
of the curve for an interval had this
formed logarithm of the of the length of
the interval uh and this at least for
people like Frank as an orbit around
anyways people who think about condensed
matter Theory uh this is the well-known
formula for the Von Neumann entropy of
an of an interval in a conformal field
Theory all right scales is the logarithm
the separation or the length of the
integral so you know it's working
um so you haven't yet Justified the Ryu
take me I have not justified so I'll say
that it was when like sometime around I
even forget when it was but around 2008
uh I think when they proposed it they
proposed it phenomenologically yeah they
did a number of examples they found
stuff like this where it seemed to match
they said maybe maybe uh length of the
minimal curve is the formula for entropy
um and eventually uh liquids and all the
same I gave an argument
um I am not going to give that argument
uh but
yeah it's a complicated yeah it's it's
an argument which
um at the level
I'd say we're confident in you know it's
not a proof because it involves path
integrals on You Know Field theories and
so on and so forth yeah things that we
can't mathematically yeah say are well
defined but it's a you know at the level
of the way that people do physics you
know there's nothing
nothing controversial about him
um
if I change the stay on the boundary
am I affecting some to change the metric
in America oh yes and that's what
changes yeah exactly true yeah
um yeah so the metric you mentioned was
for some specific State on the Monday
that you haven't told us
can you just repeat whatever you were
saying about the interpretation of s of
a for a conformal filter oh uh yeah well
just that in a conformal field Theory
um
you could choose your favorite conformal
field Theory right just say like some
Icy model or something uh and then you
can calculate you know you can say well
I can find I'm going to find the ground
state I'm going to diagonalize the
density operator I'm going to take the
sum of uh minus Lambda log Lambda for
all the eigenvalues so I'm gonna I'm
gonna ask you how does uh how does the
F3 babe you can do that calculation it's
a hard calculation but it's been done uh
and the answer is maybe it's like this
with the log
um
inside what is Epsilon correspond to in
the cfd sorry
what is Epsilon here correspond to is it
the uh
the
the ultraviolet cutoff
sorry going back to I've been asked
question so if I have a different state
on the boundary do I have to like redo
all of these calculations they're like
oh so
um good question
um
so the the basic answer is
the this ads CFT correspondence will
only hold four certain kinds of
interacting theories on the boundary
right if you just have a ring of cudits
and you just write down some random
hamiltonian then it will not be
described this way right
um
the word random is actually kind of
loaded there if you choose the right
distribution of random then the answer
that will be described this way in some
circumstances but
um yeah you need the right kind of
boundary Theory
um but if you have the right kind of
boundary Theory then these conclusions
will hold
okay so I said
um
we should take the minimum over curves
you know gamma related to a but I didn't
actually tell you what the what the
relationship was between gamma and a
really
um and the mathematical relationship is
that gamma should be homologous today
okay
so what does homologous mean
um
so it means uh that if I take gamma and
a together
right so like here I have gamma and a
together uh they are the boundary
of some bulk region little a
so in this example there's a bulk region
little a
which is oops
I'll see it in green
so gamma Union a together are the
boundary of little a
so I allow myself all all Curves in the
bulk that satisfy that relation
and you might intuitively might have
thought well I just take a and I deform
it into the boundary that's that's
homotopic it's different than homologous
because some of the things that are
allowed
I could take a curve like this right and
then this would be part of my little a
as well
right so I didn't say that the region a
in the in the bulk had to be Simply
Connected or anything I could have
disconnected regions this would be
perfectly allowed uh but in this case
this would just contribute extra length
right and so yeah so we don't use it but
in some circumstances it's helpful but I
mean if big a were contiguous then would
that ever happen
um
yes really uh if there's some weird
geometry yeah
oh like if there's a wormhole or
something
um
okay so the the little a oops
this bulk region that gamma and capital
a Are the boundary of we call that the
entanglement wedge
of uh oops a big a
so the green the green region for the
optimal curve that's we call the
entanglement wedge
and the integama wedge is important
uh because
it tells us which portion of the bulk
gets mapped to which portion of the
boundary
in these theories
and so
the entanglement wed you know if I have
uh
a boundary region capital a
uh I find
um the curve that calculates its entropy
I look at the bulk region that defines
the homology
and operators in that bulk region
I can map them I can express them in
terms of operators on the boundary only
in capital a
Okay so
now I'll write that out
so for any operator capital O
located inside the entanglement wedge
there exists an O tilde oops
um
acting only in the boundary on a whose
expectation values are going to be the
same
and so if you've heard of the
holographic principle right uh wait I
haven't mentioned the holographic
principle until now right you know that
uh in a given region of space
um in some sense the uh there's a
description of that region of space only
in terms of degrees of freedom on the
boundary
um abs-cft is a concrete realization of
that because the boundary we have a a
boundary Theory it's explicitly but here
is a refinement of that uh that if we
know where the operator is located in
the bulk we can restrict which portions
of the boundary are needed to uh to
represent it
um
but this there's a whole story behind
this
um
but understanding this uh this fact
um really required thinking in terms of
quantum error correction
because there are multiple ways of
expressing this operator o in the
boundary
because I could
oh okay well
I don't have a half circle
um
so forget the bottom half of the circle
and just to imagine the top half I have
an original region a
um but here I have another another
semicircle I can have an a prime I could
also Express o in terms of boundaries on
April or operators on a prime
uh and when you start to think about the
geometry uh you find that
um
there's no single no no single part of
the boundary is required to express o
right that you can you can you can
remove an arbitrary portion of the
boundary and still be able to express o
and so o is redundantly encoded in the
boundary
right so there's a Quantum error
correcting code you know under the
surface there uh that makes this work
yeah
that's right the bulk has been purely
classical as far as
the waters are acting
acting so far the bulk has been purely
classical yes uh yeah are you going to
specify at all the Hilbert space on
which uh the volca is acting
um well I'm going to largely avoided in
this talk
um and it's a small miracle that I can
avoid it uh
the
say this issue the the information loss
question from black holes that I alluded
to at the beginning
um
it was thought for a long time that the
only way we'd be able to resolve that
question was by having a microscopic
theory of the bulk really knowing what
the what those degrees of freedom are
but we've learned that we can actually
do the calculations necessary to
understand what's happening without
having a microscopic Theory
and so it's enough to have this
semi-classical Theory which is valid uh
in the limit that gravity is weak
uh like that so that um so we can
so that the the ball gets described by
general relativity
and there's a metric instead of some
other microscopic degrees of freedom
that collectively create the metric
Quantum corrections to your entropy
formula a higher order
uh yeah higher order in
kind of one over d
yeah
okay yeah if you have a duality it
typically it means I don't need for any
absurd episode
oh uh yes so if you're gonna have a
semi-classical bulk the map is many to
one
uh like the the statement about the
isomorphism but the actual quantum
gravity theory is an isomorphism uh but
in the semi-classical theory of the bulk
there are more degrees of freedom that
can be included in the boundary and so
that's I'm not going to get to it but
that that gives rise to its own set of
questions there's a nice paper by Dan
Harlow uh Chris Akers and others
recently on non-isometric Quantum codes
which uh is kind of addressing some of
the conceptual issues there directly
where if you if you want to understand
the correspondence for the
semi-classical bulk Theory to
um to the boundary CFT that that's we
can discuss that offline but I
um
so we're actually coming up on
the end of the first half I think so
maybe I'll just do one thing I don't
know how long your
um you know you're given the time for
discussion is not taken away from the
elections oh okay well you let me know
when I should stop I don't I don't want
to exhaust
we've said above where arguments from
what
this one's here yeah yeah
um
so the this entanglement web transaction
argument yeah yeah
um how do you make that work
um so you need formulas not just for
entropy but relative entropy and it
turns out that you can get relative
entropy from the entropy yeah oh so
that's this paper by Jeffers at all uh
and then in the exact case
um sort of
exact in a certain sense you know
there's Escape by Don Carl the wall and
then we wrote a paper a little while
afterwards so it shows how to use
quantum information ideas really to
construct this bulk to boundary mapping
um and Omar Fozzy's in the room right so
this is the theory of universal recovery
Maps uh that if you have monotonicity of
the relative entropy right if you have a
Quantum Channel isopro Sigma mapped to
entropy of s of channel of row acting on
channel of Sigma you have the entropy
relative entry has to go down if it only
goes down by a little bit Omar and R all
told us that there's a reversal map and
that reversal map is actually basically
the map that gives us uh the bulk to
boundary mapping
um said very quickly but Quantum
information played a key role there
okay so this homology condition Scott
was asking you know what kind of
circumstances and what kind of
circumstances does it matter
um so here I have two intervals
um
in
in ads or in a spatial slice and the
entropy of the A1 interval
is calculated
by or has this
by this curve and as the entanglement
wedge A1
the A2 interval
has
entropy length of gamma 2.
and if I put them together into a single
region that I'll call Capital a which is
the union of A1 and A2 uh then it works
out in this example
that the entropy of a is just the sum of
the lengths of Gamma 1 again
but the homology condition
tells us that we actually have two
choices
right
um
so again now I have interval A1 interval
A2 but I've made them bigger
okay
and by making and
the condition the homology condition
was that I have to think about bulk
regions
whose boundary uh
or
whose boundary is the union of A1 A2 and
whatever pieces I consider
so the dotted lines
are the analogs of gamma one and again
it's two in the first picture up here
and
the intervals A1 and A2
Union the yellow uh
are the boundary or rather the intervals
A1 and A2 Union Gamma 1 gamma 2 are the
boundary of the of the yellow right and
so these dotted lines are perfectly
valid choices for calculating the
entropy
but
here's
another bulk region
and now the boundary of this bulk region
are the solid lines gamma 3 and gamma 4.
and remember the length of one of these
geodesics uh is the log of the boundary
length and so the solid lines their sum
is less than the the lengths of the the
dotted lines
and so in this example
the entropy is given by the sum of the
lengths of
gamma 3 and gamma 4.
and why is this interesting
well
it means that when we're asking about an
operator say located in the center where
the star is
um I couldn't reconstruct it in A1 I
couldn't reconstruct it in A2 on the
boundary but I can reconstruct it in the
union of A1 and A2
um and before Quantum information
appeared on the scene that was something
that no one knew how to do in ads cfd uh
no one knew how to reconstruct one of
these operators that was outside of
these regions so that was one of these
uh one of the advances
you're saying it's enough that there's
some bulk region that for for like I
mean what what if the minimal geodesics
are just you know they they they uh
Define a region that's just the uh uh
that does not include
then you can't necessarily do it and you
can't yeah it's all it's only uh it's
the bulk region
for the homology of the optimal curve
right okay wait I have another question
why isn't the region the union of that
topmost wedge and that bottom most
little waves there why does it actually
include the uh hourglass well
uh
the the definition is that A1 A2 Union
gamma 3 gamma four should be the real oh
yeah uh yeah no you could have done the
opposite sure
hold on hold on uh
yeah no um if I if I took these top and
bottom regions
um
all right
A1 and A2 are not part of the boundary
right of this region they don't satisfy
the condition properly
okay uh but I I I I say okay so so this
so this this wedge reconstruction I
don't you know understand that I don't
understand the conditions for it okay
okay you're saying
uh okay because okay there is a way to
do it so A1 and A2 have to be big enough
that it really looks like this
uh and once they're and it doesn't look
like the other possibility and once it
is big enough then I can reconstruct the
sentence is what you're saying uh yeah I
guess so oh
okay um okay
okay yeah that's yeah
okay fine
okay
it's up to me
um you know what are we positive
discussion to to extend the talk so it
yeah
um let me just take a quick look uh
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]